[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 18 mai voici
les titres c'est le dossier chaud sur la
table de la nouvelle première ministre
elisabeth baume le gouvernement devrait
être annoncé dans les prochains jours
les noms de certains yvelinois sont
évoquées pour faire partie de ce
remaniement et du maire de poissy karl
olive à la députée aurore bergé en
passant par l'ex ministre délégué à la
ville nadia ont fait le point c'est le
pari de deux jeunes entrepreneurs
proposées quotidiennement la livraison
de boissons dans des bouteilles
consignées l'objectif permettre aux
consommateurs de réduire leurs déchets
nous les avons suivis lors d'une tournée
dans le nord des îles vite et puis
découverte des aides lessons à la fin de
cette édition ce club installée aux
clayes-sous-bois pratique le quidditch
depuis 2010 est c'est le sport des
sorciers issus de l'univers harry potter
mais avant de développer ces titres il
est nommé auprès de la nouvelle première
ministre thomas la vielle devient le
chef de cabinet d'elisabeth bornes
l'arrêté a été publié au journal
officiel ce mercredi le haut
fonctionnaire quitte ses fonctions de
directeur de cabinet du préfet des
yvelines qu'il occupait depuis 2020 le
préfet jean jacques brot lui a
d'ailleurs rendu hommage dans un tweet
il le remercie chaleureusement pour son
travail accompli avec tak efficacité et
élégance dans l'intérêt de tous et au
service de l'état fin de citation et
depuis la nomination d'elizabeth borne à
la tête du gouvernement le remaniement
se fait attendre avec le nom des
prochains ministres certains n'ont
d'ailleurs circulent et parmi eux
quelques heavy noah qui peut prétendre à
un ministère éléments de réponse avec
mathilde aux francos
si aucune date n'a encore été annoncée
la liste des noms des prochains
ministres ne va pas tarder à se faire
connaître alors quels sont les élus
yvelinois pressenti au gouvernement en
fait le point le maire de poissy arrive
en pôle position karl olive a déjà
accueilli plusieurs fois le président de
la république dans sa ville ils ont même
joué au foot ensemble lors du match
célébrant les 50 ans du variétés club de
france en octobre dernier c'est aussi à
poissy qu emmanuel macron a décidé de
lancer officiellement sa campagne
présidentielle en mars le pisciacais
donc dans les faveurs du président de la
république après avoir rendu un rapport
en février sur l'insertion des jeunes
par le sport dans les quartiers car le
livre pourrait être pressenti au
ministère de la ville et non pas à celui
des sports en raison d'un conflit
d'intérêt sa soeur brigitte henriques
étant la présidente du comité national
olympique et sportif français
autre mère yvelinois présumés au
gouvernement arnaud péricard ce dernier
a lancé en octobre un comité de soutien
à saint germain les pour porter la
candidature d'emmanuel macron étant sous
la bannière horizons ce serait le moyen
de faire entrer au gouvernement un
soutien de l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe il est également
l'avocat de nombreux sportifs et là
notamment défendu rabiot ancien joueur
du psg et tony yoka boxeur yvelinois
arnaud péricard serait donc pressenti en
tant que ministre des sports il y aussi
l'ancien ministre de la ville à nadia et
membre de la commission des finances
elle pourrait repartir pour un nouveau
ministère en 2020 elle avait participé à
un rapport concernant l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière
nadia et pourrait donc se voir attribuer
un nouveau ministère comme celui de
l'économie et des finances les députés
yvelinois jean-noël barrot et aurore
bergé ont également leur chance
déjà pressenti à l'économie en 2017 est
actuellement vice président de la
commission des finances jean noël barrot
pourrait peut-être se faire une place
tout comme aurore bergé la députée a
rendu en 2020 un rapport sur le
développement de la culture pour tous
elle pourrait donc être présentes
ministère de la culture cependant parmi
toutes ces personnalités une seule
serait vraisemblablement choisi
elizabeth emmanuel macron doivent se
résoudre à trouver un équilibre
géographique afin de ne pas présenter un
gouvernement trop parisien la seule
certitude le futur gouvernement sera
resserré autour d'une quinzaine de
ministres et sera en place avant
vendredi 20 mai dans l'actualité
politique les élections législatives
approchent les électeurs éliront leurs
députés les 12 et 19 juin prochain tv 78
vous aide à y voir plus clair et vous
dresse les enjeux du scrutin dans
chacune des 12 circonscription des
yvelines ce soir direction la 2e
circonscription avec célia get on go
bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78 quelles
sont les communes déjà concernés par
cette circonscription alors on l'appelle
versailles chevreuse de cette
circonscription est située au sud est du
département vous l'aurez compris elle
englobe le sud de versailles les villes
de chevreuse choisel bucs magny les
hameaux vire au fréon encore
vélizy-villacoublay
depuis 2010 est c'est le député le
député de cette circonscription c'est
jean-noël barrot candidats en marche et
qui sera de nouveau investi en 2022 sous
la bannière ensemble regroupant des
partis de la majorité présidentielle
un des buts et qui n'est pas issu des
rangs de la droite une première sous la
vème république
valérie pécresse a été élu en 2002 2007
et 2012 lors des élections partielles de
2016 c'est son suppléant pascal thévenot
mer les républicains de
vélizy-villacoublay qui a été très
largement élu avec 72 85% des suffrages
exprimés c'est donc une petite surprise
lorsque jean noël barrot membre du modem
est en tête en 2017 au second tour avec
58,3 % des voix contre pascal thévenot
avec 41,7 pour se retrouver pour cette
élection 2022 on prend un peu les mêmes
et on recommence un peu un bis repetita
by très vite repetita oui pour les deux
candidats de 2010 7,1 du second tour
improbable match retour se dessine
jean-noël barrot devra défendre son
mandat pour l'emporter une seconde fois
si l'on prend les résultats du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
emmanuel macron est en tête avec 33% des
voix à versailles contre 14% pour
valérie pécresse arrivée quatrième
derrière jean-luc mélenchon emmanuel
macron est également devant avec 38% à
viroflay 32% à vélizy villacoublay et
37% à chevreuse et si on met de côté ses
deux candidats le casting change pour
les autres partis oui marc soriano de la
france insoumise qui était arrivé
troisième en 2017 ne sera pas au casting
cette année avec eux la nouvelle
alliance de la gauche baptisé 1 us
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale c'est une candidate europe
ecologie les verts maïté qu'arrive b
doit ni qui est investi habitante de
viroflay depuis 30 ans elle a annoncé
qu'elle fera campagne à vélo avec une
son suppléant pour le rassemblement
national ce sera gaëtan bros il a été
candidat pour les départementales dans
le canton de montigny le bretonneux en
juin 2021 mais d'autres candidats
continuent sont encore en lice même si
le fond de faibles scores comme céline
julier étiqueté extrême droite en 2017
elle avait tout juste dépasser les 1%
lors des dernières législatives elle
retente sa chance cette fois-ci sous la
bannière reconquête le parti et d'eric
zemmour qui a fait d'assez au bon score
à la dernière présidentielle dans les
communes concernées jérémy et bizet du
rassemblement des écologistes de la
droite et du centre se représente une
troisième fois né à chevreuse et vivent
maintenant à jouy en josas il a
rassemblé pour les deux dernières
élections les élections moins de 2% des
suffrages exprimés deux autres
candidates ont aussi à déclarer leur
participation aux législatives
il s'agit de clara ferrer pour le parti
animalistes et de hélène janis et pour
lui ouvrir toutes les informations sur
cette 2e circonscription des yvelines on
rappelle les dates 1 12 et 19 juin pour
ces élections législatives merci célia
400 go
[Musique]
le journée de job dating demain jeudi
dans les yvelines avec deux événements
proposés autour de l'emploi à vélizy
villacoublay à 19 postes sont à pourvoir
chez les enseignes de lusine mode et
maison le site donne rendez vous de 9h à
12h en partenariat avec pôle emploi la
mission locale de versailles la ville de
vélizy villacoublay profil recherché
d'employés de la restauration et de
conseillers de vente pour des cdi cdd et
de l'alternance pour participer les
candidats devront se munir d'un cv et du
côté de versailles la ville propose
également à un job dating mais à
destination uniquement des jeunes c'est
de 13h30 à 17h à l'hôtel de ville 27
recruteurs du secteur public ou privé
seront présents jobs d'été emploi
étudiant en alternance premier emploi en
cdd ou cdi dans les domaines de la
restauration de la garde d'enfants de
l'animation ou dans l'accueil
munissez-vous également de votre cv les
inscriptions se font directement sur
place ou sur le site internet de la
ville de versailles nous vous proposons
à présent une découverte dans ce journal
c'est la tournée un nouveau concept
lancé en novembre 2000 21 par deux
jeunes entrepreneurs il propose la
livraison de boissons au quotidien avec
des bouteilles consignées l'objectif
c'est de remettre au goût du jour la
consigne mais aussi de permettre aux
consommateurs de toute l'ile-de-france
de réduire leurs déchets pour l'heure la
tournée passe par les départements des
yvelines et du val d'oise justin brasier
et nicolas landry les ont suivis
[Musique]
tous les clients commandent sur notre
site on aime on leur préfère leur
commandement b on est quasi un peu à
l'ancienne comme celui ci
donc chaque client commande une deux
trois caisses donc là je suis en train
de préparer la commande du client qui
habite à chatou j'ai commandé douze
grandes bouteilles pour elle a livré
dans une caisse comme ceci non à une
application mobile pour pouvoir préparer
toutes ses commandes cette clientèle a
commandé 6 7 6 pétillante donc gbagbo
qui vient des vosges
pour ce palier d'envoyer vous avez un
pack d'eau donc six bouteilles d'eau
quelques jus et une bouteille de vin ça
c'est un panier qui entre 25 et 30 euros
giala et donc le véhicule a chargé toute
la nuit ja il a suffisamment de
batteries pour la tournée à venir
notre objectif c'est que les gens aient
puisse diminuer leur impact justement en
passant à la consigne donc on a voulu
être cohérent et est utilisé une flotte
de véhicules uniquement électrique pour
minimiser l'impact de la livraison
si maintenant on peut partir en tournée
ça m'enlève quoi
[Musique]
on est parti on va vers notre premier
point de tourner car oui donc c'est à 15
min cela de notre entrepôt
le client à recevoir un texto en lui
disant
la tournée passe dans x minutes c'est
également calculé automatiquement et
donc le client va savoir un peu pour se
préparer ou alors pour mettre sa caisse
devant chez lui si s'il a juste envie
qu'on fasse les changes sur le pas de sa
porte bonjour c'est la tournée oui
voilà
donc là en fait on a dit ok très bien je
vais récupérer les bouteilles vides oui
et je vais écouter et ça va être crédité
automatiquement
validé la livraison je mets 10 grandes
bouteilles recrédité la consigne et
c'est bon
au revoir
[Musique]
à chaque livraison on récupère les
bouteilles vides et de la livraison
précédente en fait au moment du passage
de commande des clients payent une
qu'aucune consigne donc ça fonctionne un
peu comme une contre une caution et au
moment où on récupère les bouteilles en
fait on valoir crédité cette consigne
est donc une fois qu'on récupère toutes
ces bouteilles vides on va les trier
dans cette allée là donc là vous voyez
vous avez uniquement des bouteilles jean
on n'écrit pas référence aux par
fournisseurs j'ai l'idée donc de toutes
ces bouteilles vides c'est que elles
proviennent uniquement de fournisseurs
qui ont un système de réemploi c'est à
dire que c'est des bouteilles qui vont
être lavés et réutilisées aujourd'hui
avec ses premières entrepôts on a pu le
réemploi vingt mille bouteilles
notre objectif c'est de réemployer 500
milles en 2022 et en espère être en
bonne voie pour cela fait il ya beaucoup
de consommateurs qui sont sensibilisés
au sujet des déchets des cons pas
vraiment de solutions pratiques à portée
de main en fait et puis de l'autre côté
aussi des industriels les petits
producteurs ils ont soit ils ont envie
de ba de proposer des formats consignés
soit ils sont qu'avec la régulation
qui va être de plus en plus
contraignantes ils vont plus avoir le
choix sauf qu'en fait ils n'ont pas
vraiment de canaux de distribution
adaptée aujourd'hui et nous c'est ça en
fait on a voulu créer avec la tournée
c'est vraiment ce chaînon manquant pour
pouvoir permettre la collecte des
contenants à chaque nouvelle livraison
le but ça va être vraiment de s'étendre
sur toute la grande couronne en
commençant évidemment par par les
yvelines
[Musique]
également le val d'oise où on va ouvrir
une quinzaine de villes le mois prochain
et donc pour vraiment pouvoir livrer
tous les tous les clients en ile de
france
[Musique]
le 75e festival de cannes s'est ouvert
hier et se déroule jusqu'au 28 mai pour
vous faire vivre cette grande fête du
cinéma radio sensations un partenariat
avec tv 60,18 va à la rencontre des
réalisateurs acteurs et producteurs de
la région ile de france chaque année
aussi ce sont les exploitants de salles
de cinéma art et essai qui se rendent à
cannes pour échanger avec leurs
homologues ou encore dénicher à quelques
trouvailles on retrouve sur place
corentin halouze et nous avons croisé
michel hinton directeur du ciné lab dans
les yvelines bonjour bonjour vous êtes
venus ici à cannes ou pour les
rencontres nationales de la fca et
l'association française du cinéma d'art
et d'essai qu'est-ce que vous êtes venu
faire concrètement ici bas c'est un
rendez vous important et je dirais aussi
important que les projections du
festival parce que là d'abord on se
retrouve entre entre professionnels
entre personnes qui ont des salles entre
exploitants et en plus on voit des films
dans des conditions confortables on voit
des films qui sont à la quinzaine à la
semaine de la critique dans des
conditions très confortables donc on est
un rendez vous incontournable pour nous
or le cinéma d'art et d'essai comment
est-ce qu'il se porte depuis la reprise
de crise sanitaire est ce que ça je suis
compliqué mais bon on va pas arrêter de
faire de la et c'est parce que l'arrêt
c'est un petit coup de mou donc non il
faut continuer à passer des films de
qualité donc souvent non pas y arriver
et distributeurs indépendants et on va
continuer à soutenir justement c'est le
moment de son client en plus les petites
amies les films que vous avez vu cette
année est ce qu'il ya des films qui vous
ont marqués plus particulièrement oui
alors ça commence à la moi je n'ai pas
vu énormément j'ai vu le louis garrel
l'innocent hier énorme coup de coeur
voilà moi je suis pas j'ai je vois là
louis garrel je connais comme comédien
mais là je les ai découverts vraiment
comme un metteur en scène qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de talent et je pense qu'on
reparle de son film mais c'est un vrai
coup de coeur que j'ai eue pour la pour
l'innocent le festival ça fait plusieurs
années que vous venez est-ce qu'il a
changé depuis les débuts oui alors là il
faut remonter loin je suis venu pour
voir fois ici en 1984 donc
oui il ya beaucoup plus de monde en plus
moi j'ai eu la chance de travailler dans
le dans le réacteur au festival de trois
ans donc pas après ça reste l'euphorie
on est dans une bulle
on pense qu'au cinéma donc ça ça change
pas merci beaucoup michel hinton d'avoir
été avec nous et puis avec plaisir mais
aussi un mine de festivals et on
retournera de nouveau à cannes dans ce
journal d'ici la fin de ce festival
programmé le 28 mai avant de refermer
cette édition coup de projecteur sur les
aides l'essonne c'est une équipe de
quidditch des clayes-sous-bois depuis
2017 les adhérents pratiquent ce sport
issu de l'univers harry potter mais quel
ennemi d'euros et justine brasier s'y
sont essayés regarder
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais enfourché mon balai
pour vous présenter l'équipe d agent qui
est basée ici aux quais sous bois
[Musique]
pour lui présenter ce sport insolite je
suis aux côtés de gilles qui est père
fondateur qui est également coach joueur
qui fait un peu tout ici alors gilles
qu'est ce que c'est ce sport alors le
quidditch en fait c'est un patchwork de
différents sports on a le rugby pour les
contacter on a le handball pour la forme
du tir on a le cardio beaucoup de cardio
parce qu'il faut savoir que le terrain
qui est derrière nous fait quand même 44
mètres de long pour 3 de large donc ce
qui est assez long et on peut aller
marquer derrière comme devant au niveau
des buts et on a aussi le ballon
prisonnier donc le dodgeball donc on a
des ballons de zwolle qu'on se tire
royalement dessus donc sert là c'est un
sport de tout ça c'est un mélange de ça
et ça porte mixte on le voit derrière il
n'y a pas de balle et un ses
bâtons quels sont les autres différences
avec la saga harry potter et ce sport
qui est devenu un vrai sport oui c'est
devenu un vrai sport en fait il ya une
coupe de france et une coupe d'europe ya
une coupe d'europe des nations il ya une
coupe du monde que les etats-unis ont
gagné contre la belgique en italie avant
de coheed donc là il ya une nouvelle qui
devrait arriver donc la france est
sélectionné donc elle va y aller aussi
donc cocorico et oui bah en fait tout
est différent le ballet on ne veulent
pas on court avec les ballons de deux
ball les ballons de les cogneurs les
c'est devenu des ballons de football le
soin fait un ballon volé dégonfler qu'on
peut tenir une main et en fait c'est une
sorte de contrainte d'avant le ballet
parce qu'il faut toujours avoir une main
dessus ou d'avoir toujours entre les
jambes si on l'a pas on oublie de
toucher ses cages il ya également le vif
d'or je crois qui apparaît en deuxième
partie de match si je peux dire
quasiment on va dire presque à la fin
parce que ça arrive à la 18e minute donc
à partir de dix huitième minute on a
donc
un joueur qui vient mais que le familles
sortent jaune que j'ai là avec une balle
de tennis dans une chaussette et le but
c'est d'attraper le vif d'or sans
toucher le joueur donc c'est un peu
compliqué ils ont voulu tester aux états
unis avec un drone mais ça n'a pas fait
long feu le drone a été cassée
directement après ces explications sur
ce sport place à l'entraînement je vais
tester ces disciplines
[Musique]
là on est bon voilà la même si tu
t'écartes un peu c'est pas grave par
contre si vraiment tu commences à sortir
la déconsidérer tomber c'est comme si tu
étais touché par un cognard donc ballet
au dessus de la tête tu vas toucher
tebbutt et après je croyais alors monté
sur son balai et la semelle ok
[Musique]
ah oui c'est fini
j'ai testé j'approuve ce sport le
quidditch et les environs 400 licenciés
enfoncé une quarantaine de clubs
maintenant c'est à vous d'essayer et
pour en savoir plus sur le sport le plus
célèbre chez les sorciers rendez vous
lundi prochain dans l'émission 7 8 sport
présentée par michael et demi d'euros
justement à l'antenne chaque lundi sur
tv 78 voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité
on se retrouve dès demain pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]